all right guys
bang bang lunch money is back for the
second
episode before we get into this episode
though we want to tell you we're
starting a new
lunch money channel if you go into the
description
or you go to the top pinned comment in
this video
click on the link and go and subscribe
to that channel moving forward starting
tomorrow
that's where we're going to upload all
the lunch money videos go subscribe
if you like lunch money go there and
that's where you can get the lunch money
video
but before we get into that don't forget
block five is the sponsor if you want
the block five credit card you have to
go to blockfy.com
pomp you gotta sign up for an account
and then join the wait list they're
going to start handing out the credit
cards here shortly
about 10 days or so is when people will
start to get them
so make sure you go to blockfi.com sign
up for the wait list
and you'll get the bitcoin rewards
credit card from blockfi
what's up go subscribe
to our new channel so we can get all the
views
okay job openings in april soared to a
record 9.3
million i was going to say dollars 9.3
million jobs
as the economy rapidly recovered from
its pandemic
depths the standard set in april was
well above the 8.3 million in march
that itself was a new high going back to
2000.
wow this is job openings right
well that means people aren't working at
them but because everyone's quitting
because the government is just giving
them free cash
but that's going to end soon and when
all of the pandemic relief runs out
we're going to see a mad scramble for
people to get back to work
because while the government's giving
you free cash it's great to sit at home
but when they stop giving out the cash
you got to go back to work but isn't
this good news that people are hiring
after a year no no no but that's the
difference is
yes there are some of this is just pure
hey we're hiring
but a lot of it is actually that people
quitting their jobs has exploded as well
and so that's where you're getting the
job openings is i had a job now i quit
so that's a job opening that got added
yeah it does say one big challenge for
employers is finding available labor
child care issues ongoing fears about
the pandemic and the lure of enhanced
unemployment benefits
have kept the unemployment rolls at 9.8
million
about 3.6 million higher than before the
pandemic
there's also a shortage of strippers i
read an article today
they can't find enough strippers facts
for real go look it up
i don't know if that's an only fan's
thing i don't know if that's an
unemployment thing
i don't know what it is but there's a
shortage
are you interested in the job hey you
know call me
i mean i need seven figure payday you
want me to strip but you know we could
talk
oh my god this took a turn okay um apple
detailed the future of iphone software
at its annual event wwdc
worldwide developer conference um there
are a bunch of new things
one of them that i like that i think
people have been asking for
for a long time and it doesn't seem that
complicated yet
they have not released it until now is
on your imessage
you're you'll be able to um
oh i lost it you'll be able to basically
mark a mess a text message is unread and
come back to it
is it doesn't that sound great how often
do you think you're gonna do that
oh my god so often really yeah you
respond to everyone almost immediately
do not yeah me on the other hand i can't
even find my phone
that's also true but listen to this one
um
so uh icloud is adding a new digital
legacy feature that will make it easier
to give access to someone in the event
that you die so i guess a lot of people
when they die they have this um
rich library of photos and messages and
and whatever guys a really good profile
to read on this and it's really creepy
it's called
speak comma memory i think it's on the
verge
look it up it's based on this when i die
i hope they burn my phone i hope they
literally destroy it so badly
that you'll never can you do it do it
while you're still alive
what's next
what's next you don't think that's funny
if i thought it was funny i would have
laughed all right well i think it's
hilarious and so
on the other hand are laughing over here
like a hyena warren buff
warren buffett's berkshire hathaway
makes 500
500 million dollar investment in a
brazilian digital bank
i got 500 bucks to throw into his 500
million it's called um
it's new bank an investment in the
parent company of new bank which is a
privately held digital bank based in
brazil
so what is berkshire hathaway doing
investing in digital banks
berkshire hathaway is going to have to
eventually stop being a value investor
because value investing is dead
from a sense of buying cash flow heavy
capital intensive businesses
instead what they're going to start
trying to do is invest in technology and
disruption
they're also going to look for mispriced
assets in the market so if they're
investing they actually think it's
undervalued compared to where it will be
in the future
so the principles of value investing
will still apply but the types of
businesses are going to change they're
going to push more and more into
technology
companies this is a perfect example also
it does say warren buffett's berkshire
hathaway there's no way warren buffett's
leading the investment
so younger people people who are more
technology kind of savvy they're the
ones now that are getting onto the
investment team they're starting to lead
some of these investments
rather than warren buffett and charlie
munger themselves great
so a company called relativity space uh
raised 650 million dollars led by
fidelity
and joined by investors including
blackrock and tiger i'm still laughing
about my joke
okay sorry germany spain
is you want to laugh so hard come on
in three minutes i have things to do
relativity space raised 650 million
dollars led by fidelity and joined by
investors including blackrock and tiger
global
as the company steps up to work on a
fully reusable rocket
that will attempt to challenge elon
musk's spacex
in less than three years can they do it
probably not why not
they probably can't beat spacex at
spacex's game
but they can probably be the number one
3d manufacturer
uh and or manufactured rockets so they
can
be the best that they can be it's kind
of like lyft and uber like you're not
going to beat uber at uber's game but
you can be the first lift
and so similar here is that yes
technically they are in the space
industry and people are trying to pit
these against each other
but i actually don't think that there's
a lot of uh comparison between spacex
and relativity but that's a good thing
for relativity not a bad thing but i
actually think that
it's good that there's competition now
because spacex there was none and with
this
if there is competition maybe they can
like make it cheaper and make it more
sustained like
innovation tends to accelerate when
there's competition
man i am a quote machine these days
what's going on with the texas mom
arrest all right um
a texas mom was arrested after posing as
her 13 year old daughter
at school because she said she wanted to
do a social experiment to prove there
was a problem with the school security
measures
turns out those security measures kind
of worked
she was she trying to do she dyed her
hair she tanned her skin put on big
glasses and a marvel hoodie
to test the school's security and
impersonate her daughter
and she got arrested yeah sounds like i
was doing something crazy well she got
caught because during the last period of
the day a teacher
asked her to stay after class and
apparently she
she look the mom says she looked at me
she's like you're not
julie and then she had to take off the
mask and the glasses and admitted
she was her mom and they got her own
criminal trespassing and tampering with
government records
uh what i mean she used child i'm glad
she used her daughter's school id number
so my question what was the daughter
doing
during the social experiment my mom was
like i want to pose and go to school
like you have to be like all right no
problem
i gotta go to school today [ __ ] you can
go for two days that's me
no problemo anyway do we have any
questions
um so the last topic of the day was the
big news
which is oh
go to the link in the description or to
the top pinned comment and subscribe
to the new channel if you want lunch
money you got to get to the new page
by the way i met moist in person this
weekend
me and moist we were hanging out fist
bumping
drinking we never know what could happen
he's drinking from
water as well because he's not 21.
me and moist hanging out if you want
lunch money go to the new
page it doesn't look so great yet but
we're quickly going to upgrade it so
just make sure you subscribe
click on the link and hit subscribe
click on the link hit subscribe link in
the description or link at the top of
the comments go and subscribe
to lunch money if you want to continue
getting this awesome content
at polina puts together thank you bye
leave no for real leave bye
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but eight point
six percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfy
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends